first of all let me just Linger on some
crazy ideas so uh one the strong force
just stepping out and looking at all the
physics
is it weird to you that there's these
forces and they're very particular like
it operates at a very small distance and
then gravity operates at a very large
distance and and they are all very
specific in the standard model describes
uh three of those forces extremely well
and there's and misses one of them yeah
this is one of them it's just all kind
of works out there's a big part of you
that's uh you know an engineer that you
step back and almost look at the
philosophy of physics
so it's interesting because as a
scientist I see the universe through
that lens of essentially the interesting
things that we do are through the forces
that are get used around those and
everything works because of that
Richard Feynman had uh I don't know if
you've ever had Richard fine it's a
little bit of a tangent but she's never
been on the pocket he's never been on
the podcast he was unfortunately passed
away but wanted like a like a hero to
almost all all physicists and then part
of it was because of what you said he
kind of looked through a different lens
at these but typically look like very
dry like equations and relationships and
he kind of I think he brought out the
Wonder of it in some sense right for for
those
he posited what would be if you could
write down a single not even really a
sentence but a single concept that was
the most important thing scientifically
that we that we knew about that in other
words you had only one thing that you
could transmit like a future or past
generation it was very interesting it
was um so it's not what you think it
wasn't like oh strong nuclear force or
Fusion or something like this and it's
very profound which was he was that the
reason that matter
operates the way that it does is because
all matter is made up of individual
particles that interact each other
through forces that was it so just that
atomic theory basically yeah
which is like wow that's like so simple
but it's not so simple it's because like
who thinks about atoms that they're made
out of like I I this is a good this is a
good question I give to my students how
many atoms are in your body like almost
no students can answer this but to me
that's like a fundamental thing by the
way it's about 10 to the 28. out of 28.
so that's uh you know trillion or you
know million trillion trillion or
something like that yes so one thing is
to think about the number and the other
is to start to really Ponder the fact
that it all holds together yeah it all
holds together and you're actually that
you're more that than you are anything
else